now watch some of those fights not the
greatest card of all not the greatest
card of all time curse blades you know I
got the job done he's [ __ ] he looks
the curse blades striking looks like
he's catching angles I've never seen him
do I think he's working with Christian
Allen yeah cuz he looks he looks really
good and and his takedowns I think he
knew the game plan against Volkov was to
take him down over and over again which
he did he he gassed a little bit which
five rounds fight that's a lot of bodies
let me 18 take down three attire buckle
oh yeah not the best performance like
he's not gonna toss out after that no
not a chance
I I do think he's he's number for first
place for pride win streak he's a he's a
problem for everybody well Francis igano
says hold my fist because he's beat him
twice I didn't know that so okay
um but he's he's a monster he's right
there but you know he they haven't met
three hmm uh him and Derek Lowe should
definitely fight their glue says the
fight coming up though hey shout out to
Cody Donovan look great right [ __ ]
Cody Donovan is uh I mean great corner
man his fighters are doing amazing Oh
dudes crushed man the number boys are
crushing it but yeah you know yet ste
paid Cormier fighting August 11th so the
rubber match Francis will fight the
winner of that then Curtis blades
probably unit one more he wins one more
than him top shot he's one away from the
top shot okay the problem is do you
really let's say Francis beats the
winner of DC steepen right you really
want to see Curtis blades with France
Francis three even though he's Owen - I
it's just like it's a it's I tell you
why I'm intrigued by it i I folio a lot
of them has gotten better okay
since they last fought which would be
Francis you don't think cursed place
looks looked a little bit different than
his striking things I look worse hmm
yeah you were he knocked out Junior dos
Santos yeah but do you feel gassed in
five yeah and you know in volkov you
know dad zero takedown defense so it's
like he couldn't finish him down there
so if I have to say who since they last
fought who would I put my money in
Francis beat I'm gonna push back because
in my opinion Francis and Cano has so
much power but if you watch him his
actual when he's the regulars technique
of rock a little bit that's do a little
bit you know why that's it works for him
but I'm saying I don't
that you can say he got better where you
can say is he's incredibly powerful and
he bum-rush them caught him but I will
defer his record he dries like Francis
beat since his last fight with yeah yeah
doesn't go so your base it off of the
rosin stroke fight yeah I am you saw
about the twenty second blitz we had no
reason every guy that's a silly well now
let me ask you this you like Cain
Velasquez I like came back screaming
twenty-six second I like old Cain
Velasquez I think that was a different
game Oh curse blaze is good though be in
45 seconds no no listen if you he has a
nuclear weapon in both hands if you get
caught with huh let me just go over his
last five fights he beat Curtis blaze in
45 seconds
he beat king Velasquez in 26 seconds
he'd be Junior dos Santos in a minute he
beat Rosen strike in 20 because you
can't but again he when you're that
powerful that fast and that big if I see
your point yeah we don't know yet I'd
like to see him fight steep a again and
see what he looks like DC they are
neither one's gonna be a great now D say
now DC and you know he's my favorite
heavyweight of all time only because of
his physicality I do because I fight a
heavyweight but that's fine I just I
just love DC okay that's just super real
I was a heavyweight sled no no I
understand that I just think to me the
most impressive heavyweight all time is
is Daniel Cormier most impressive yeah
because of because yeah I think is own
stature and yeah and I yeah and so it's
probably my favorite - but that's rude
to say I'm still here I understand I'm
sorry that you're hurting and my eyes
are itching like a [ __ ] game
huh I am and did you throw those to my
eyes just now now now here's the thing
about him here's the thing about Daniel
Daniel fought steep a and just kept
walking in and just we was winning just
waiting and just back back back he just
when he gets you this he's too smart for
that if he does that with an Frances big
trouble oh yeah you don't well it was
steep it you know a steep a it's hard
but with Frances like you're knocking
like I won't do that again it's just
over yeah yeah boy boys suck into 205
for Daniel
look at how hollow his eyes are
no dude anybody who says that's that he
I used to always say he'll find it two
or five five two two or five but I mean
oh and he's one of the greatest
heavyweights of all time and every wait
why would you fight you yeah III can't
wait god it's real thick though I can't
wait for that uh that rubber mat I I
don't this isn't he'll sleep on steep a
you can say he's one of the greatest of
all time on a percent dc's dwell time I
I don't want to I personally don't want
to see steep a and and Cormier fight
again
for the simple reason that they
especially steeply took so much damage
what's happening I'll just eleventh bro
I know he took so much damage I don't
want to see him take he wasn't speaking
right but he won that frame damage there
knock them out I know and I'd rather let
it let it lie I'll let him bolt you
rather than both I want Daniel retired
yeah I'm with you too yeah I want Daniel
retired we can't you know they're
fighting so I'm excited for it but I'm
with you I'd rather both them just say
laughter that's how I feel because I
think nothing approved because I think
Francis beats both of them and I don't
want to see steep a take a shitload of
damage to his head even if he wins
against Cormier to the head again and
then fight and then be diminished and
fight and gone oh I'm getting really I
must say this B I think it happened with
JDS happened with Kane it's happened
with Verdoux they're happening with more
[ __ ]
there's Rory McGaha you don't get so
many hits no matter if you do it all in
that night in a 10 fight streak you get
so many hits that's right so when when
Francis and steep a fought that first
time and I was at the fight C Bay won
that fight he took some all the power
that France had to offer
yeah he beat him yeah and Francis
learned from that fight but steep a got
took some shots knew crazy you think
about steep a JDS took some shots dude
yeah and steep it Harris fight
Steve face head you could live in his
head he's so big you could I would say I
would say you could put two of cheese no
no papa cheating's got a head on him
if Jim put this hat on which I'm wearing
it would look like a yarmulke how was he
able to fit let me wait never fit let me
see that happens you got a big head
people are like I don't have a big head
I have a small head up here that thing
it's not gonna even come on that's a
yarn Ivan
to the side that's a head alright that's
a head I have a giant it like steep his
head if you holler that would be a
modest house for four
yeah it could house a family Shane's is
a small mansion the biggest head you
know that's a big head you can't wait
like you there baseball like I guess you
don't get a hat Stephen Lucas is so big
when I saw him in person and I was a bit
away from him but he looked so big he
seemed sizes me Oh guys 64 but his head
is so much bigger yeah that's what it is
yeah a giant it next to Mark Hunt more
country shorter oh God some big but
Stevie doesn't get the credit deserves
money someone disgraced I've been heavy
weights to ever do it sound [ __ ]
great off him being DC there's arguing
he's the best and he saves lives dude he
look he goes into fire he saves live
visit and he's a blue-collar guys I'm
gonna remodel my kitchen you [ __ ]
Cleveland blue-collar stuck on he's a
legend in Cleveland dude
he's thought about steep a he's a legend
in my household you say he should be
he's a legend really close it's nuts
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]